>> Kennedy: MAJOR
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE JUSSIE
SMOLLETT SAGA IT CONTINUES.
A COOK COUNTY JUDGE IS
APPOINTING A SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR TO INVESTIGATE
THE HANDLING OF THE CASE BY
CHICAGO TOP PROSECUTOR FOXX
AS YOU REMEMBER HER OFFICE
DROPPED ALL CHARGES AGAINST
THE ACTOR A BIG SURPRISE.
HE WAS ACCUSED OF STAGING A
HATED CRIME ATTACK ON
HIMSELF.
TOUGH TO DO.
THE JUDGE SAYING THAT FOXX
DID NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO
ASSIGN HER TOP DEPUTY TO
LEAD THE CASE AFTER SHE
COLLOQUIALLY RECUSED HERSELF
IN A STATEMENT FOXX SAID
THAT SHE DEGREES
THAT SHE DISREES
THAT SHE DISAGES
THAT SHE DISAGREES WITH THE
JUDGE'S DECISION.
EMILY, THIS IS REALLY
FASCINATING, YOU ARE A
LAWYER, CAN YOU EXPLAIN THIS
BETTER.
I WAS WONDERING IF THERE WAS
SOME DOUBLE JEOPARDY HERE
BUT THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
SAID NO THEY CAN REOPEN THE
CASE AND JUSSIE SMOLLETT CAN
BE CHARGED ONCE AGAIN WITH
ALL 16 COUNTS FEWER OR EVEN
MORE.
>> YES, AND ANYONE ELSE THAT
HAS BEEN CAUGHT UP IN THIS
CAN BE CHARGED AS WELL.
I WANT TO POINT OUT FOR
VIEWERS A COUPLE THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, THE JUDGE, JUDGE
CAME OUT SWINGING AT KIM
FOXX.
HE SAID ESSENTIALLY THAT THE
PHRASE SHE USED THE ACTING
STATES ATTORNEY BASICALLY
WAS MADE UP IN HER
IMAGINATION AND, THEREFORE,
THIS IS THE IMPORTANT PART,
THE ARREST, THE SUBSEQUENT
PROSECUTION AND THE DROPPING
OF ALL CHARGES, THEREFORE,
IS INEXPLICABLE.
IT'S LIKE WIPING THE SLATE
CLEAN ALL MOOT.
LIKE IT RESTORES THE ENTIRE
SITUATION BACK TO THE
ORIGINAL PLACE.
SECONDLY, THERE IS A WHOLE
HOST OF CONCURRENT
INVESTIGATIONS HAPPENING.
AND HERE THE DEFENSE WAS
ARGUING WELL, LOOK WE ARE
DUPLICATING THE EFFORTS OF
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL JUDGE
CONSUME MINUTE SAID YOU ARE
NOT.
FOR VIEWERS WE HAVE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
WE HAVE NOW A SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR.
THE FBI INVESTIGATING THE
HOAX.
WE HAVE THE CITY OF CHICAGO
LAWSUIT AGAINST JUSSIE FOR
COSTS AND THEN DON'T FORGET
SUED ATTORNEYS.
SHE BLAMED HER ETHICS
OFFICER ON IT AND SHE RAN ON
THAT PLATFORM OF I AM GOING
TO INSTILL AN ETHICS OFFICER
AND BRING ETHICS BACK TO THE
CITY OF CHICAGO.
>> Kennedy: OTHER THAN THE
FACT THAT THIS IS HIGH
PROFILE ACTOR AND THE WHOLE
CASE IS WEIRD WE ARE STILL
SO FASCINATED WITH THIS.
>> Doug: WE ARE.
AND NOT WITH UNDERSTANDING,
EMILY, WHAT YOU SAY, JUSSIE
SMOLLETT.
>> Jesse: JUSSIE.
>> Doug: SORRY.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO IGNORE
OR DROP THE DOUBLE JEOPARDY
ARGUMENT.
THIS CASE IS GOING TO TAKE A
WHILE IF IT EVER COMES TO
TRIAL.
AND THERE WILL BE
SUBSTANTIAL ARGUMENTS THAT
IT IS DOUBLE JEOPARDY AND MY
HUNCH IS WE MIGHT GET A PLEA
OUT OF THIS FOR A VERY
MODEST OFFENSE.
>> THE WAY HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT IT.
HE FELT LIKE HE WAS
SCOT-FREE.
I'M MY MOTHER'S SON AND
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT I WOULD
NEVER DO ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
THE REAL ATTACKERS ARE OUT
THERE.
>> Jesse: THIS IS WHY
AMERICANS THINK THE WHOLE
SYSTEM IS RIGID BECAUSE
MICHELLE OBAMA'S FORMER
CHIEF OF STAFF MAKES A DUAL
FOXX AND HE GETS A
SWEETHEART DEAL.
COMEY GIVES HILLARY A
STACKS THE TEAM WITH 19
DEMOCRATS.
CELEBRITIES PAYING CASH
BRIBES TO GET THEIR KIDS
INTO SCHOOL.
SNEAKY SNIPES MESSING AROUND
WITH THE VOTE COUNT.
ALL BOGUS IF YOU ARE A
REGULAR AMERICAN WORKING
HARD YOU FEEL LIKE IF YOU
ARE NOT SOMEONE POLITICALLY
CONNECTED OR RICH, YOU CAN'T
REALLY WORK THE SYSTEM IN
YOUR FAVOR.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE ARE
OBSESSED WITH THE STORY AND
THEY WANT TOP SEE JUSSIE PAY
A PRICE.
>> Kennedy: LORI LOUGHLIN IS
NOT GOING TO PRISON.
>> Greg: I THINK JESSE CAME
UP WITH BOOK PROPOSAL.
YOU JUST DID YOUR TABLE OF
CONTENTS I HAVE TO HAND IT
TO JUSSIE SMOLLETT HE DIDN'T
JUST SINK HIS OWN CAREER BUT
THE SHOW EMPIRE AND
DESTROYING KIM FOXX'S.
HE IS LIKE THAT PAINT
CANISTER THAT BANK TELLERS
SLIP INTO THE MONEY BAG AND
GIVE TO THE BANK ROBBERS
ALMOST THERE AND THE WHOLE
THING EXPLODES AND COVERED
IN PAINT.
MY SOLUTION FOR HIM AND I
HAVE SAID THIS BEFORE HE
SHOULD COME CLEAN AND MEET
WITH THE PEOPLE THAT HE
SMEARED.
HE SMEARED THESE IMAGINARY
MAGA SUPPORTERS.
IF HE ACTUALLY DID A MEET